difficile pour le ministre de
l'éducation de trouver des insatisfaits
dans cette école élémentaire de poissy
le dispositif du dédoublement de classes
promesses de campagne d'emmanuel macron
a été ici mises en oeuvre dès la rentrée
2010 est pour les cp et étendue cette
année au ce1 cette école de poissy est
emblématique que nous voulons pour
l'ensemble de la france en réalité les
professeurs sont amenés à faire toute
une série d'innovations avoir des petits
ateliers à travailler de façon plus
personnalisée
on voit des parents qui sont très
heureux de cette situation qu'ils sont
dans un lien plus étroit avec l'école et
qui participe à cette logique de
réussite de leurs enfants dans le
département des yvelines 350 et une
classe de 71 écoles sont concernées
cette année des classes dont la moyenne
du nombre d'écoliers a chuté à moins de
douze élèves alors même que nous sommes
dans en ile-de-france dans des
territoires qui sont réputés défavorisés
et parfois en difficulté
en réalité vous avez ici je dirais des
graines d'optimisme même constat pour le
maire de poissy
cette mesure serait une réussite à long
terme il ya une meilleure motivation de
la part de ces jeunes qui sont sans
complexe jeudi sans complexe parce que
comme je le disais monsieur le ministre
tout à l'heure nous sommes ici sur un
quartier prioritaire donc c'est un outil
d'intégration à nulle autre pareille
les seules critiques autour de ce
dispositif concerne le manque de locaux
disponibles dans certaines écoles mais
dans les yvelines
on a trouvé la solution dans ce cas de
figure les enseignants travailleront à
deux dans la même classe